Donald Trump is also now admitting he's
gonna try to cheat in 2024. Mike pillow
found out about this and is not in
agreement with Donald Trump this is
super super interesting Donald Trump put
out a statement I missed this originally
but this is just Bonker stuff Trump put
out a statement saying we need to beat
Democrats in 2024. and of course the
Democrats cheat it's like no no no you
tried to steal the election but put that
aside he insists Democrats chief we need
Trump says to start ballot harvesting
just like they do we need to do the
ballot harvesting now Mike pillow has
been slamming ballot harvesting alleging
that Democrats do it and I'll explain
what it is in a moment
for two years now so pillow's Furious so
let's listen to what Trump had to say
first the radical left Democrats have
used ballot harvesting to cancel out
your vote and walk away with elections
that they never should have won they
cheat and they cheat like nobody's ever
cheated before
many states have bad ballot harvesting
to keep our elections honest and fair
but in the states where ballot
harvesting is still legal we have no
choice but to beat the Democrats at
their own game it's very simple either
we start ballot harvesting
or you can say goodbye to our country
you want to wave goodbye because
Democrats would win every single
election we have to get smart and that's
why our campaign will fight back and
start harvesting ballots whoa the states
where the left has been cheating the
scourge of ballot harvesting which they
will now participate in the system and
hurting our country but our harvested
ballots will only come from legal
registered voters who are American
citizens ah you're going to harvest
ballots but from legal voters whereas
Democrats were harvesting ballots from
illegal voters
with your help we will Master the
Democrats game of ballot harvesting and
we will win back the White House from
Joe Biden and the people that are
destroying our country okay so ballot
harvesting means you collect and submit
com completed ballots on behalf of
Voters so the idea is there's someone
who says I will collect the ballots you
fill your ballot out I will go and
collect it and it's a technique used to
increase voter turnout especially when
there are people who have a tough time
getting to polling stations either
because they uh live very rarely and
don't have a car or they have a physical
limitation or a whatever the reason may
be in general the term ballot harvesting
means oh I will go and collect ballots
now the legality varies from state to
state and jurisdiction to jurisdiction
in some places it's legal and regulated
in some places it's illegal some states
say you can do it but you can only do it
for family members and caregivers you
can't just have the person on your block
who says I'll I'll collect everyone's
ballots and drop them off or whatever
the case may be it's become a very Hot
Topic in the U.S recently
because
the right is arguing the left harvests
ballots but they do it with coercion
they encourage voter fraud they get a
bunch of illegal voters to fill out
ballots and then they collect them
there's no evidence of any of this stuff
but it's what the story they've been
telling so Trump's saying we should do
it puts Mike pillow in sort of a strange
position and Mike pillow says I spoke to
Trump about this he's never going to say
it again it's a voter fraud but also
recently he's been saying let's beat the
left at their own game at least until we
get into office so that no no no no
don't even go there I've talked to him
about them we are not going to do what
they're doing we're not going to ballot
Harvest we want we and you will not hear
him saying that this is we've worked two
years to get to get same-day voting
paper ballots handcuffs he's a I've been
I've been killing myself I spent 35
million
fighting against ballot harvesting and
now Trump's going to do it on a no
machine and if you say that we want to
do what they do ballot Harvest and do
this the the Republicans would just make
it legal to do what's illegal in a lot
of States and it's over we lose our
country so that narrative you will not
hear him saying that anymore I don't I
don't even want it yeah pillow didn't
even really want to talk about it so
pillow says no no no no no no no I heard
about that I went to Trump we're not
going to be talking about that anymore
we can't really do it so this is this is
obviously fascinating and it doesn't
seem totally clear to me whether Donald
Trump understands
the the issue is less about obviously
any kind of ballot collection regardless
of the state or jurisdiction you can
only collect legal ballots like if you
somehow again imagine the scenarios they
dream up if you somehow find ten
thousand blank ballots and bring them to
people who aren't registered to vote I
guess you have to find find ten thousand
undocumented immigrants who of course
they're going to live all over the place
and you're going to drive around
Distributing ballots to undocumented
immigrants and then picking them up
obviously that's illegal because the
voters aren't legal registered voters
The Collection is what's at issue in
some places anyone can collect ballots
for others in other places it's limited
to family or caregivers there are
different rules in different places in
Trump's mind he's just like well
Democrats do ballot harvesting but with
illegal ballots whereas we're going to
do it with only legal citizens but we're
going to help them he doesn't even
actually understand the controversy over
ballot harvesting which isn't surprising
because increasingly he doesn't really
understand anything